you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is another
group of five puzzles and each of them
is white to play and it's up to you to
determine the best continuation so go
ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation for white ok
the solution to puzzle one is first
Queen f6 and if the rook is to black
it's an immediate mate with rook e8 and
if the Queen is to block well white now
wins the Queen by attacking it she is
now in a pin and the consequence of
taking the Queen well that would be mate
so that's solution to puzzle 1 moving on
to the second one once again white to
play pause the video see if you can find
the best continuation ok the solution to
this one is Queen takes Knight and the
idea behind this is that if if the pawn
takes the Queen now we give check a
purposeful check and after the King
moves we get that Queen and why does
that material and we'll win this endgame
position however the important detail to
recognize is that what do you do as
white if black now takes the rook a
Powner sacrifice and in this case if you
immediately recapture the Queen well now
you lose your Queen back and black is
the side who's winning however it's
important to see the follow-up move
after Queen takes rook what do you do
now the shot is Queen takes f7 if the
King goes to the corner well we give me
and if rook takes now you take the rook
with check and then at this point take
the Queen and now of course the tables
have turned in white will be the side
winning this one
so that's the solution to puzzle 2 it's
important to see not only Queen takes
Knight but also what to do should the
Queen grab the rook in this case Queen
takes f7 is it moving on to the third
one white to play pause the video see if
you can find the best continuation ok
the solution to this one is actually a
retreating move Queen to d1 of all moves
it may have been tempting to play moves
such as 95 or Knight to b5 they are
certainly forceful hitting the Queen and
actually quite typical would be
something like Knight d5 in a Sicilian
like position
is one that we kind of have here but
recognizing that this bishop on d6 since
it has one attacker and one defender you
can you should view this or at least
could view this as being unprotected and
this night as well well he's just
unprotected isn't he
no attackers no defenders so he's
unprotected the bishops are protected
and you can actually make use of both
ideas white with this Queen 2d one move
will be picking off either the bishop or
Knight winning material and the game
moving on to puzzle for once again white
to play pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation ok the
solution to this one his first rook Fe
and if the King tries to run away this
is an immediate made on g6 so takes rook
is forced and now we don't immediately
recapture the rook but rather throw in
this in-between move Queen d5 if the
rook is ever blocking well you could be
taking it and you could be giving check
and then finally mate so the other try
is after the Queen gives check on d5
King age 7 now what do you do you take
the rook with promotion to a knight and
now there's only one reply and at the
end night on e to g6 delivers mate all
key squares are now covered so I'm
moving on to the fifth and final once
again white to play pause the video see
if we can find the best continuation ok
the solution to this one is rook II
takes b7 and now what exactly to do
about the threat of rook to b8 main well
Knight takes rook and now this is the
silent but best move rook to b6 and it's
surprising to see with such a minimal
amount of material and black still
having a queen on the board there's
nothing that could be done about either
rook to a6 or rook to b8 on the next
turn to give me if black is defending
like this
that's made on b8 any other move is
essentially allowing rook takes a6
there's only computer like moves to
delay the inevitable with taking on c2
for check but that's of course still
just going to be lost so that's the main
idea take ng
excuse me b7 with the e-book and then
follow up with the silent rook to b6 and
there's nothing that could be done about
the rook taking on a6 or going to be 8
for me so that's all for this video as
always let me know how you did in the
comment section below and I'll catch you
in the next video take care bye